what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another installment of our
beyond omega level series where we
discuss the powers and feats of the
strongest characters in all of comic
books and for today's video we're going
to cover a character that i'd be willing
to bet most all of you haven't heard of
and whose name i haven't heard in a long
long time like not even joking i haven't
thought about this guy since i was like
13. and back then i'd refer to this dude
as like the living meatball because he
looked like one right like he looked
like a walking i mean look at him the
guy looked like a walking talking
meatball but nonetheless one of the
things you guys may not know or most of
you guys may not know is this guy was
the most powerful herald of galatus
until thor became galactus herald during
donnie kate's run of course we're
talking about morg the executioner now
morg was created by ron mars and ron lim
and first appeared in silver surfer
number 69 in 1992 and while we don't
know a whole lot about morgue's
backstory they were a race that existed
out in space there were aliens they were
pretty advanced and one has to wonder
how did this alien race become so
advanced did it just happen right was it
the fairy godmother no it wasn't no it
wasn't ladies and gentlemen you know
what it was y'all know what's coming
skillshare that's exactly how they
became so advanced and so intelligent so
for real and for true and you guys
should know this by now skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of inspiring classes for creative and
curious people where you can explore new
skills develop existing interests and
get lost in creativity now one of the
things you guys may not know is that we
have a tick tock account and honestly i
had never really used that platform
before but thanks to skillshare
specifically janos herman who has an
entire course called tick tock marketing
101 grow your brand and business my
staff and i were basically able to
figure out how tik-tok works because
this course has things like finding your
target audience the different content
formats on tick-tock how to create viral
content analysis and content
optimization because the community over
there is just a whole different
community and so using this kind of
information we were able to grow it and
turn it into something bigger so whether
you're looking to learn photography
video editing marketing make sure you
check the description and the first 1
000 of my subscribers to click on the
link in the description will get a one
month free trial of skillshare so you
can start exploring your creativity
today having said that back into our
video
so yeah morg's backstory isn't really
explained all that much but what we do
know about him is that he was once a
member of a group of rebels that tried
to overthrow the queen of his planet now
after the revolution fails morg is given
the chance to have his life spared by
turning on his fellow revolutionaries
and serving the queen which he basically
does the queen makes morg the planet's
executioner and he carries out his first
assignment of essentially killing off
all his former allies in service of the
queen now when galactus showed up to
devour morg's planet morg meets him and
displays no fear which wins the respect
of galactus and prompts him to offer
morg the opportunity to become his new
herald which of course morg accepts and
so as he does with all of his heralds
galactus imbues morg with the power
cosmic now one of the primary reasons
galactus thought morgue would be a
suitable herald was his ruthless nature
which was a welcome change from his
previous herald a human named frankie
ray that gained powers similar to those
of the human torch and then began
calling herself nova which by the way
frankie ray was just great back in the
day but galactus problem with her was
that she would basically spare planets
if they were inhabited by sentient life
even if they would have been sustainable
sustenance for galactus and so with
someone as cold-blooded as morg galactus
wouldn't really have that problem now
not long after morg is brought on as his
herald galactus is confronted by the
silver surfer who was unaware that nova
had been dismissed and replaced now
galactus dispatches morg to battle the
silver surfer and during this battle we
see morgs power on full display he's
able to use his double-bladed axe to
absorb the silver server's energy
attacks and is even able to drain energy
from the surfer by touching him now the
battle concludes with morg using his
ability to project energy blasts against
the surfer and he's able to render him
unconscious so right off the bat we know
this guy is extremely powerful because
knocking the silver surfer out who is
well in and of himself just ridiculously
powerful requires an insane amount of
power and after experiencing how
ruthless morg is in battle the surfer
appeals to galactus to reconsider his
selection as a herald but galactus
ignores him now knowing that something
needs to be done about morgue before he
starts a blazing trail of destruction
across the galaxy silver surfer seeks
out the other heralds like firelord
terex nova and airwalker and if we don't
know anything else about these
characters we know that they were all
heralds at one point which means they're
all pretty powerful because usually once
you become a herald when you leave you
normally maintain the power that you got
from galactus so of course this lets us
know how big of a threat morgue really
is and so while the surfer is assembling
his team of former heralds morg is
leading galactus to planets for him to
consume and he comes to a planet where
he finds a well of life which the
planet's inhabitants worship for its
healing properties now when morg gets in
the well he finds his powers have been
augmented even further than they were
before morg describes his newfound
powers as a combination of cosmic and
mystic in nature and declares that he
now embodies power itself and so morg
then boasts that it is within his
ability to destroy the planet himself as
well as anyone who would oppose him and
as he leaves the planet he makes a
fairly large crater in its surface and
so with both the power cosmic and the
power of the well of life at his
disposal morg's first test of his power
is to take on the team of former heralds
assembled by the silver surfer now not
long after the battle begins the heralds
realize even their combined efforts will
not be enough to take down mork tarax
even comments that the team of heralds
is unable to compete with morg and that
he is more powerful than any and all of
them and so the silver surfer then leads
the battlefield to try to reason with
galactus once more and morgan makes
short work of air walker reducing him to
a pile of scraps and so morg then turns
his attention to firelord and nova and
remarks that his power level is far
beyond that which was granted by
galactus to any of his other heralds now
morg then manages to disarm firelord and
drive his axe into firelord's chest
which takes him out morg is then
attacked by terrax to set up an epic
battle between these two guys wielding
axes and morgue's axes proved to be far
superior as it breaks terrax's axe on
impact and i mean terrax literally has
the word axe in his name so i mean this
is apparently serious business right mid
1990s comics morg then manages to
incapacitate terrax but before he can
deal the killing blow he's blindsided by
an attack from nova now silver surfer
then returns to the battle and he and
nova start talking which leaves nova
vulnerable enough for moore to strike
her in the back with an energy blast
from his axe and kill her and so
galactus is not pleased with morg for
killing nova since in galactus mind he
was her creator and so galatus strips
morg of the power cosmic although he
retained the powers he gained from the
well of life and then following that
morgue has to battle the former heralds
and is able to fight evenly with all of
them at least at first he's able to
endure blast from silver surfer as well
as a punch to the head from terrax
eventually however the combined efforts
of the heralds prove to be too much and
terrax manages to steal morg's axe and
then use it to kill him or at least
that's what the heralds thought as it
turns out because 1990s comics were
nothing if not just insane there was
still some life left in morgue due to
the power of the well of life and he's
brought back to life by galactus who
gives back the power cosmic and although
morg is still extremely powerful he
doesn't appear to be at the same level
he was after entering the well of life
still morg is extremely formidable after
having been restored by galactus and was
able to defeat terex in battle and even
battle thanos evenly until being
distracted which basically gave thanos
the upper hand morg's able to wipe out
an entire fleet of scrolls ships by
himself and in a rematch with firelord
and airwalker morg is easily able to
emerge victorious however in a battle
with the silver surfer morg is
eventually defeated after a back and
forth fight between the two which is
still pretty impressive considering how
powerful the silver surfer is now
eventually morg is taken captive by a
villain known as tyrant who was actually
the first herald of galactus and i don't
remember if we did in a mega level video
on him but that guy was op but after
escaping and returning to galactus
morgue manages to obtain the ultimate
nullifier one of the strongest artifacts
in marvel comics with enough destructive
power that even galactus is afraid of it
now morgue uses the ultimate nullifier
against tyrant and tries to escape it
before it destroys galactus ship but he
is caught in the explosion and then
killed with the only other instance of
us seeing him was when annihilus
unsuccessfully tried to obtain the
remnants of the power cosmic from his
corpse so yeah that's basically
everything you need to know about morg
the executioner not a character that
gets talked about a lot but at the
height of his power he was way too much
for the silver surfer and an entire team
of former heralds meaning he's way
beyond omega level but let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section right you you guys want us to
cover more just like obscure but
ridiculously op characters because in
all honesty we're running out of popular
op characters so i guess the obscure
ones are ones that we should focus on
next let me know what you guys think as
always leave your suggestions down in
the comments and i will catch you all
later
peace
you